Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, since so many
of you asked me to say something about the
Spider-Man Marvel Sony stuff I thought I’d
do something fun and list my Top 5 new actors
I think could pull off peter parker.
There are so many reasons why Spiderman might
never appear in a Marvel film so I’ll do
a breakdown of the bigger ones.
Don’t get super excited.
Most of you will probably have one or more
children before Peter Parker ever gets invited
to a party in the Avengers Tower.
Important stuff first everyone has already
been spamming new actors for Spider-Man.
In case you don’t know, Marvel wants to
show Andrew Garfield the door.
I guess they’re not huge fans of his.
That doesn’t mean they hate him, it just
means if they used Spiderman, they wanted
a fresh take on the character.
If Andrew Garfield guest starred in Civil
War or Infinity War he’d bring all the Amazing
Spider-Man movie baggage with him.
Marvel wants absolutely nothing to do with
any pre-existing Spider-Man movies.
Even the Sam Raimi ones.
Normally this wouldn’t be a huge deal, but
Sony Re-Booted Spider-Man with Garfield incredibly
fast after Spider-Man 3.
And he’s currently under contract for 2
more sequels, that includes Spider-Man 4.
When they announced all those Spider-Man Spinoff
movies, he wasn’t a part of that.
Spider-Man wasn’t going to be a big character
in those.
Cut to the giant mess of developmental hell.
A lot of big producers signed to work on those
films had to bail because it was taking too
long to get Sinister Six, Venom and the other
movies going.
Which is when the Marvel Spider-Man talk started
happening.
As much as Sony’s film unit has been in
decline, Marvel has been on a home run streak.
The only reason they haven’t reached a deal
yet is because of money.
Marvel wants a lot and sony doesn’t want
to give them the majority of the profits from
any crossovers.
So will it ever happen, probably.
Will it happen in the next 10 years?
Maybe.
And only with a new actor.
Thus, here are my TOP 5 candidates for a new
Peter Parker.
I’m going to do a thumbs up thumbs down
for each of these and I’ll address the Miles
Morales comments after.
Number 5 - Dylan O’Brien
Thumbs Up: He has genre experience and most
of the characters he’s played have been
Peter Parker types.
So he knows the drill.
And no matter which Marvel film Spider-Man
appears in, it’s only going to be a supporting
role.
So he won’t be completely responsible for
carrying the story.
He’s got name level recognition even though
I consider him a B-Level blockbuster star.
Marvel tends to go after actors that are on
the rise so they don’t have to pay their
actors too much.
Robert Downey Jr is the exception.
They cast him before they started their 6-picture
deal standard contract.
Thumbs down on Dylan: Even though Spider-Man
would only be a supporting character, a bad
choice of actor could sink the movie.
Spider-Man is a huge deal.
No matter how much we see him on screen.
Number 4 - Ansel Elgort
Thumbs Up: He’s a great with Drama, and
Spider-Man drama is at the core of the Civil
War comic book storyline.
Marvel isn’t doing the comic book storyline
for Civil War, but they can graft some of
that into Avengers Infinity War.
Anytime he’s with the Avengers, Spider-Man
is a boy being taken advantage of by Asshole
older Heroes.
He’s like the impressionable little brother.
So if they want to stay true to that, Elgort
can play that.
And he’s the right age.
A very young 20 something Spiderman.
He even looks like he could still be in high
school if they want to go that young.
Thumbs Down:
They only real experience he has in an action
movie is the Divergent Trilogy.
And he hasn’t shown that he can pull off
that twitchy hyper active quality that Peter
Parker has.
Number 3 - Anton Yelchin
Thumbs Up: He has a strong indie drama experience
and big blockbuster genre experience.
Chekov kind of is the Peter Parker of the
Enterprise in the new JJ Abrams films.
Plus he’s even wearing Spider-Man red now.
Thumbs Down: scheduling conflicts with the
Star Trek Sequels could be a problem.
They haven’t set a date for Star Trek 3
yet, but it’s happening.
After that there’s potential for them writing
in a new cast.
Or writing out Chekov so he’d be free to
do other really big movies.
Typically big movies can shoot for up to 6
months, not including re-shoots and the time
they have to spend promoting the film all
over the world.
So scheduling is the big reason this probably
won’t happen.
Number 2 - Nicholas Hoult
Thumbs Up: All the same reasons as Anton Yelchin.
But I feel like Nicholas Hoult has a little
more on screen presence and he can carry a
big movie.
Thumbs Down:
Same reason as Chekov.
The X-Men Franchise is in the middle of making
Apocalypse, they’ll be shooting soon.
Small upside, the cast of those movies are
so big that they can easily write Beast out
of the films without a lot
of explanation.
Number 1 - Jamie Dornan
Thumbs Up: He’s getting ready to be the
biggest star on the planet once Fifty Shades
of Grey comes out next year.
He can carry a film, he’s not super expensive
because he’s still considered an up and
comer.
And he has a lot of genre experience.
Thumbs Down:
He’s probably too old to play Peter Parker.
No way can he pull off impressionable youth
living with Thor, Iron Man and Captain America
next door.
If they decide to go with an older spider
man, then it might work.
And he’s currently not signed to another
mega-franchise yet.
Although they probably will do a Fifty Shades
sequel.
So what about the Miles Morales Spider Man?
The reason people aren’t talking about him
with marvel a lot is because Avi Arad and
Matt Tolmach, the producers of Spider-Man
have said the character will only ever be
Peter Parker.
Legally right now, they control that kind
of thing, no matter if Sony gives the character
to Marvel.
So if you want Miles Morales, you have to
get the rights away from them.
Not Sony.
I know it sounds confusing.
But they have the rights to the character
and they signed a long term contract with
Sony.
Next Big Question: Say it all works out and
Sony Agrees to share Spider-Man with Marvel
before they shoot Civil War.
What does Marvel do with the character?
Easy answer, he gets introduced in a supporting
role in Civil War and then becomes a fullblown
Avenger sometime during the first Infinity
War.
Like a battlefield promotion.
The Thumbs down on this is that they probably
won’t reach a deal in time to get him into
Civil War, at least for a meaningful role.
They’ve already written the script for the
movie, it’s not going to be based on the
Comic Book Civil War.
I know this pisses some of you off, but they’ve
already changed so much of the comics.
The biggest thing being Ultron and The Vision’s
backstories.
So Civil War will not revolve around Identity.
Second Thumbs Down:
If he becomes part of the Marvel movies, Sony
won’t be able to make Spider-Man movies
the way they want.
Marvel would have to be given control of the
character, and starting in 2017 Marvel has
three movies scheduled.
Guardians 2, Thor 3 and Black Panther.
When you also consider the DC and Star Wars
films coming out that year, it looks way too
crowded to support a solo Spider-Man film.
Meaning Sony would lose the lion’s share
of it’s biggest box office franchise.
And Sony as a company has been doing terribly
lately.
There’s no way they can go 6 or 7 years
without the money from a solo spider-man film.
James Bond, their next biggest franchise,
isn’t enough to carry the studio by itself.
Those I think are the biggest reasons why
this Spider-Man marvel thing won’t work
out the way we want it to.
I think it’s more likely that it would happen
after Avengers Infinity War.
By that time, they can re-cast a lot of the
bigger marvel actors like Captain America,
Thor, so the marvel verse will be changing
enough to accommodate Spider-man in a big
way with a new actor.
It also gives Sony the time to get it’s
shit together to the point where it’s financially
feasible for it to sign a bunch of profits
away in lost Spider-Man solo films.
Here’s the long shot.
They’re still casting Civil War, they won’t
start shooting till late spring next year.
After the Avengers 2 press tour.
So if we don’t hear anything official about
a new actor being cast as Spider-Man before
Avengers 2 comes out.
Don’t plan on it happening.
Here’s my big question for you guys would
you rather see Spider-Man as a small background
character in Avengers Infinity War.
Or would you be willing to wait till Phase
4 for
him if he could be a major character in the
marvel universe.
So is it cameo right now or big freaking deal
in 5 years.
I would rather wait and see them doing something
more canonical but I’m not going to flip
if he gets a small cameo that has absolutely
nothing to do with the comics.
Right now it’s a fascinating idea, it just
doesn’t seem like a reality.